good morning on behalf of the organizers
and with sincere thanks for the support
we've received from the star east asian
library the Weatherhead East Asian
Institute the Donald keen center
Japanese culture the Japan Chamber of
Commerce the cv star foundation the
department of east asian languages and
cultures and the film division in the
school of the arts i'm pleased to
welcome you to our first Makino
symposium I especially want to
acknowledge a few individuals at the
outset this great Makino collection
would not be at Columbia today were it
not for the devotion and quick thinking
of a treasured alumna my former student
the distinguished Japan film scholar
Joanne bernardi or for the responsive
ears she found in Amy Heinrich whose
tenure as director of the star east
asian library was marked by many
accomplishments perhaps none more
resonant than the effort she led to see
that the Maquis no collection made its
way to columbia the head of the entire
columbia library system Jim Neal long
recognized the importance and championed
the acquisition of this archive and
arranged for the disposition of funds in
its maintenance we owe Donald keen who
recently took he leave of Columbia and
our Island for his other Island home a
special debt of gratitude it was Donald
who came forward at a crucial moment
with a donation in support of the Maquis
no collection one among many of his
generous parting gifts to us i also want
to publicly thank my very active star
library colleagues and friends who have
warmly embraced this collection and care
with it and care for it with evident
pride Jim Cheng whose own scholarly
expertise in areas of Chinese film and
asian film history and whose energy and
fresh leadership of the star library
have been a joy to behold such E&O Gucci
the curator of the japan japanese
collection who has been an ever-present
indispensable guide during the period of
the Maquis no collections transfer from
japan into our system
and Beth cats off the librarian chiefly
responsible for the unpacking and
classifying of this massive archive a
task that would cripple persons less
strong than Beth in body mind and
dedication finally I want to thank
colleagues from around this country and
from Japan especially mark Norris and
Aaron zero whose connection and
affection for mr Mackey know and his
collection run deep and undergird much
of their own work as well as Rico
yokogawa motzko oya and mica tomita for
their willingness to share their own
site work with the Maquis no collection
and their own inspiring scholarship with
all of us today at both our morning and
afternoon panels we hope to begin to
unpack some of the riches of this
archive taking some measure of what it
is already contributed to rigorous film
scholarship revealing to the crucial
role it plays in the development of
Japanese film studies at present and
announcing to everyone that the archive
is very much open here at Columbia as a
source of inspiration for future
path-breaking projects it has rightly
been said that the Maquis no collection
represents the very bibliographic
foundation upon which any serious
scholar of Japanese film now stands or
else a new galaxy as Jim Sheamus has
called it a slice of kokubunji and the
teetering book stacks in the Maquis no
home suddenly appearing in Morningside
Heights to brighten our sky and even our
basement stacks forever what comes clear
too especially from the numerous
testimonials offered by film students
and scholars worldwide who once or
repeatedly found their way to the Maquis
no home and the daunting collection that
occupied its every available space is
that this is an archived put together by
an extraordinarily focused yet generous
man Makino Mamoru and that it came to
America and to Columbia in over nine
hundred boxes thanks to his openness of
mind and willingness to share
err what he had so painstakingly
assembled with the world we had hoped
that if his health permitted mr Mackey
no might make a long journey to be with
us today several of us met with his
daughters last spring and were able to
convey to them our invitation to today's
events along with what so many of us at
Columbia feel all that such a precious
archive would now be in our trust and
commitment to being worthy stewards of
the Maquis no legacy whatever else it
represents or so it seems to me the
Maquis no collection all of its over
80,000 items is fundamentally a
testament to one man's obsession we are
right to think of scholarship as a team
sport relying at most every turn on a
variety of relations connections social
networks but there comes a time when we
humbly acknowledge how much we owe not
to the collective of which we may be a
part but to the force of one individuals
desire in his actions to gather together
obsessively every kind of print matter
in text that might reveal the presence
in the impact of moving pictures surely
Japanese moving pictures but also those
made in China Korea America Russia
England France Germany India and how
from their first screenings such moving
pictures brought changes began to
condition the way people thought felt
dressed and moved about their lives
whether real or imaginary how much we
would have lost had it not been for this
man and his magnificent obsession all
praise indeed Tamaki Noma moto and to
the collection he built and means to
share with all of us passing the baton
now it is now my pleasure to introduce
Jim Neil who is indeed the person most
responsible at Columbia for the strength
and well-being of all of our libraries
and a great fan I understand of mr.
machina Fenton
you